out of the wives and sheep's clothing I
have identified three types of modern
mothers so so the first modern mother is
the you can have it all mother now these
are mothers that are adamant that they
must have a career yes they cannot not
have a backup plan their need for
comfort and the Safety and Security of a
backup plan overrides their kids' need
for a mother they either want a career
for the attention and grandios of having
a career and being able to say they were
successful or they want the career as a
backup plan because they're told Often
by their mothers that the men will just
leave you high and dry and abuse you if
you don't have a backup plan